ich habe mich heute auch dass ich sagen
aufgeregt über paula potter eine neue
abgeordnete der grünen hier sehen wir
sie die heute neu zu konstituierenden
sitzung des bundestages gekommen ist und
auf den sozialen kanälen auf
verschiedenen sozialen kanälen sich
kritisch zu ihrem bettchen in
deutschlandfarben gestern haben wir uns
darüber hier unterhalt ausgelassen hat
dieses bank in solche den zweig da sehen
wir am tor der hier ist ein deutschland
fehlt jetzt zeigt und eben darum geht es
das fand sie nicht toll das dokumentiert
den zweig staates also geimpft oder
genießen und diese frau paula passwörter
die hat die grün hat geschrieben gestern
gefühlt noch als g j also offenbar als
crew die jugend gegen zu viele
nationalflaggen argumentiert jetzt musst
du hier das hässlichste festivalbändchen
aller zeiten zu tragen hat sie
geschrieben tragen die neue grün
abgeordnete scheint also ein erkennbares
problem hat sah mit den symbolen unseres
staates die diesen symbolen des
demokratischen deutschlands und wie
anders soll man sonst ihre äußerung zur
nationalflagge verstehen gestern noch
gegen zu viele nationalflagge
argumentiert das hat er geschrieben doch
die deutschlandfahne hat nichts zu tun
mit deutschtümelei im gegenteil sie
kommt ja spätestens muss man sagen aus
der weimarer republik wurde von den
nazis abgeschafft und war ein symbol
während der nazi zeit für demokratie
menschen sind deswegen weil sie diese
flagge gezeigt haben gehen ins gefängnis
gekommen oder sogar noch schlimmer
umgebracht worden und wenn man jetzt
diese flagge
diskreditiert oder das bändchen dadurch
oder sogar in die nazi ecke stellt dann
macht man genau den fehler dass man sich
eines symbols dieses demokratischen
deutschlands das ist für mich auch sehr
für die einheit steht diese fahne
diese dieser dieser dieser flagge
entledigt eine fahnen die aufstieg
offenheit für der diversität und für
stolz auf unser land und eben nicht nur
für national denken und deswegen habe
ich da eine ganz andere sichtweise als
profi schotter denn ihr fehlt es
offenkundig an historischen verständnis
ich muss dir völlig recht geben also ich
finde es mehr als verwunderlich diese
diese reaktion der der grüne und einige
anderen grünen muss man ja dazu sagen
weil diese fahne ist ein symbol der
freiheit war immer ein symbol der
freiheit
diese fahne geht glaube oder die farben
gehen auf 1848 zurück
dass das war der grundstein der
deutschen demokratie nicht nur der
deutschen ein wichtiger moment in der
europäischen geschichte
und das zeigt nur von einer gewissen
ignoranz
dieser grünen abgeordneten das sieht das
ja anders sehen also ich kann mich gut
erinnern wie sie im frühjahr glaube ich
das wort deutschland nicht ins
parteiprogramm nehmen wollten also
einige nicht nicht aber das hat bin ich
überrascht dass das dass er überrascht
seit ich habe auch das hinführen
das findet man bei der spd bei der linke
bei den grünen das sind menschen die
eine sehr gestörte verhältnis zu
deutscher identität haben das muss sich
jetzt wieder als acht mal so sagen der
stolze deutscher ist der 2006 auch
dieses land mit den so vielen fragen
werden der sommermärchen dieses land
kennengelernt und lieben kennengelernt
und ich bin stolz teil dieses land zu
sein ich bin stolz irgendwie
mitgestalten zu können ich bin mitglied
dieses landes und ich will auch stolz
auf eine flagge sein die natürlich nicht
nur eine eine nation eine
nationalistische identität mit gibt
sondern eine eine nationale identität
einen eine identität die vielfalt die
menschen wie mich auch mit nimmt und wir
brauchen das danone diese diese
identität
haben wir eine sehr gestörter verhalten
zu uns selber und das schafft
verunsicherung und das schafft vor allem
extremismus und das schafft ein ganz
konkretes problem wir reden wir reden
sehr oft über integration und wenn wir
über integration reden dann sollten wir
bestenfalls eine vorstellung davon haben
investoren modell unrast wenn die
gesellschaft die menschen integrieren
wenn
es gab vor ein paar jahren diese lustige
debatte um leitkultur ohne eine form von
irgendeiner leitkultur ja wohin willst
du dann integrieren dann können wir es
integrieren lassen wenn wir uns nicht
einig sind dass es so etwas wie deutsche
identität gibt dann können wir auch
niemanden integrieren ahmads gefragt
warum uns das überrascht ich sagte warum
die die abgeordnet um die es geht kommt
aus leipzig und für mich gibt es einen
magischen moment aus dieser einheit das
habe ich ja noch zumindest am fernseher
damals erlebt als diese einheits oder
verhandlungen damals deutschland war
noch nicht wiedervereinigt und helmut
kohl fuhr nach dresden und hielt eine
relativ spontane rede in der nähe
so einem großen platz auf jeden fall und
und dieser platz war spontan kommt
tausende sich tausende von leuten hin
und leute hatten deutschlandfahnen und
schwenkt sie alle hatten das ddr symbol
haben wir uns sicher rausgerissen und
dieses das war eine die rede seines
lebens war gibt großartige rede relativ
spontan als in seinem kleinen zettel war
ja nicht der begnadete redner aber
dieser redner weiter rede war toll und
und diese deutschland fahren da wurde da
zum symbol für die einheit auch und sie
kommt das frisst gras das sommermärchen
erlebt 1990 jahr ist deutschland damals
fußball weltmeister im jahr der einheit
geworden ist hat diese deutschland
fahren auch noch mal das war ja eine
unbeschwertheit der auf einmal da war
dann 2006 mit dem sommermärchen
entsprechend auch also das heißt die
nationalflagge sozusagen als symbol für
deutschtümelei oder rechtes gedankengut
ist doch kompletter
premier eine ganze reihe natürlich alle
an die szene von angela merkel es war
nach einem großen waldsee herbert gruhl
waren größer und sie und sie hat diese
kommt der schöne der in der doku von
außen noch mal vorweg ein sehr schön
gezeigt wie sie dann diese diese flagge
nimmt und mit seinem fast angeekelt im
gesicht wenn er glaube da habe ich
verständnis für sie muss ich sagen da
wollte sie keine übersteigerung des
momentes haben glaube ich bin es war
eine cdu parteiveranstaltung und größer
da ein bisschen überschwänglich das fand
ich sogar unterschritten so einer
kleinen fahnen ist an den eigenen
aufgewachsen weil es überschwänglichen
also etwas anderes aber wir haben wir
müssen uns auch klar sein das ist ja
besser ich auch nicht ganz überraschend
dass wir in deutschland ein problem
patriotismus haben bei den linken im
meer und das rad ja mitten in die geräte
in einem fall widersprechen dass ich
finde eben ein symbol das für die
freiheit steht ist etwas was man
eigentlich begrüßen sollte heute ist der
nationalfeiertag in österreich 26
gratulation dober vielen dank mütter und
ist so ist gab es gab väterlich es gab
1938 am tag des anschlusses eine
berühmte rede von dem damaligen
österreichischen bundeskanzler kurt
schuschnigg
der also nach dem einmarsch der nazis im
radio seine letzte rede gehalten hat und
seine letzten worte waren bis in den tod
rot weiß rot und an diese worte erinnert
mich ja immer wieder ich bin stolzer
österreichischer staatsbürger und für
mich ist diese frage auch ein wichtiges
symbol obwohl die geschichte des landes
nicht unproblematisch ist also genauso
problematisch wenn die problematische
würden meint manche meinen als die
deutsche also insofern glaube ich dass
es längst an der zeit wäre dass
deutschland das alle deutschen diese
diese flagge hissen und stolz drauf sind
und das waren sie 2006 da kann ich mich
ja auch bis heute also zwei punkte
wichtig also ich kann das toleriert und
wenn dann normaler bürger das tun aber
wenn ein bundestagsabgeordneter das tut
dann habe ich damit ein problem das sind
unsere vertreter und die wind wegen
diese demokratische nationalstaat
eigentlich auch gewählt um uns zu
vertreten
sagt würden sie hier wen vier große
deutschland absolut und wie sie damit
ein problem haben dann sollen sie sich
auch die frage stellen ob sie da im
richtigen platz sind oder ob sie
vielleicht zurücktreten und jetzt ein
ganz ganz wichtigen punkt der schoss
nämlich auch durch den kopf weil man
muss das mal ganz ehrlich sein der
steuerzahler bezahlt ja auch die
bundestags aber völlig in ordnung ist
aber wenn dann jemand so ich fand zum
beispiel gestern sehr reizen wo sich
sagen wie viel im amt stolz sein
bändchen gezeigt morgen ich meine ist
ein großer tag der bundestag ist heute
wieder aufs neue entstanden und da ist
ein großer moment und dann diesen tag so
herabzuwürdigen ich mein wenn sie dieses
doofe bändchen nicht mag dann macht doch
nicht in stil und story darüber anlass
ist ein klebt ihr was drüber keine
ahnung und ich glaube das ist für mich
auch das ganz große problem da springe
ich die komplett bei wie kann es sein
dass eine gewählte bundestagsabgeordnete
eigentlich schon so sehr auf unsere
flagge herabschaut und damit ja auch auf
das symbol von freiheit das finde ich
auch müsste man sich unserer fraktion
extremismus an und sah zweite punkt ich
finde normaler gesunder patriotismus ist
eine der besten dämon systeme gegen
extremismus und lenker der extremismus
an das würde ich jetzt beispiel nicht
sagen ich würde sagen komisch
von extremismus das machen ja andere
indem sie das steigern indem sie dann
eine verbrecherische staatlichkeit hier
nein nein ich das hätte ich meine these
nein es geht darum dass man sich
sozusagen von etwas distanziert und dann
kommen leute und bauen darauf an und
dann steigert das bei den anderen und da
sehen wir auch wie viele leute auf der
straße zum beispiel gegen rechtsstaat
gegen polizei gegen deutschland
insgesamt gegen diese flagge auch oder
diese flagge nun alles alles anlass
finden um sachen anzugreifen das ist da
dass es nicht bei ihr entschuldigung das
wollte ich nicht sagen aber es ist ein
symptom für
weitere mögliche extremistische oder
radikalisierung zu lassen was würdet ihr
denn sagen wenn jetzt jemand
beispielsweise besagte das muss man ja
schon die einzige frage die ich für die
geschlossen ist war es denn das richtige
bank weil das wie sie sich verändert
fand ich falsch aber ich habe menschen
überlegt vielleicht hätte man auch so
eine reaktion verhindern können wenn man
ein neutraleres gehört dass du hier
schon eine frage die die die ist die ist
die ist ja da sind wir schon alle
eunuchen also wenn wir uns so eine frage
stellen dann müssen wir sagen dann läuft
wirklich was freiheit weil das ist diese
angst auch was falsches zu sagen die in
uns hinein kriegt es ist die angst
irgendwann twitter sturm das ist die
angst zerfleischen zb c c 4 c phase zu
werden in die sozialen netzwerken und
kritisiert zu werden und das ist die
angst wenn wir mit einem normalen
unserem staatssymbol einfach ein zeichen
setzen wo andere länder stolz darauf
wenn kein franzose käme auf die idee
infrage zu stellen ein solches band an
hätte oder ein engländer
amerikaner
die
singapurer oder sowas gibt es überhaupt
nicht auch vor dem hintergrund unserer
historie aber wir haben doch wirklich
hier wir wissen dass das schwarz rot
gold kein zeichen ist von einer
irgendwelchen verherrlichung der ns
diktatur ganz im gegenteil